when I on my first trip to India
I I think I landed in New Delhi and
took a room in a hotel
and that first evening I had some
telephone conversations
and I was very very happy to learn that
someone whom I had great admiration for
was going to arrive in New Delhi
the next day by train at 11 o'clock
so I was very very happy about that and
uh just took a stroll in the city and
went to Old Delhi and
on my return to the hotel
I was accosted by I guess you could call
him a fakira that means a person who has
a little bit of knowledge of yoga but
not all that much
as this fakia it costed me out of the
blue
uh and says very lucky man
so I he says oh yeah he's he's a very
lucky man tomorrow at 11 o'clock
something good will happen
well
no one in New Delhi
besides myself knew about this tomorrow
11 o'clock which is really something
that elated me
and so I must have been thinking about
it deeply
so this faki somehow picked that up out
of thin air
well this fact of course interested me
so I
went to a nearby garden with him to see
what he can have to say and so he gave
me a piece of paper and he said look at
it so I thought it was blank then he
says please fold it and hold it in your
hand so I did I held this paper
and then he said all right now think of
a number between one and the hundreds
so I thought of a number I think it was
36.
and then he says all right now open your
hand and look at the paper
and on this paper was written 36.
so I gave him something and
but on my way home
to the hotel
I brooded on this how what's going on
and I think I figured it out
the fact that he uh
he talked to me he costed me in
reference to something good that would
happen tomorrow at 11 o'clock this was
clearly a case of telepathy I mean he
was able to read my mind
so then what about the 36 that number
well I eventually did figure that out
too there is something called invisible
ink
and so that number must have been
written in invisible ink and it became
visible when I held this in my hands
meanwhile he puts that number into my
mind so there were two for us
Supernatural
uh powers that he had a to read someone
else's minds and B to put something into
someone else's mind
so here the first day in India I by
chance encountered the here
who had these two powers and you could
demonstrate that to me now why do I
speak of you well uh clearly this
these are yogic powers and you cannot
you cannot
acquire them just out of books
absolutely not